most of us on the curb parents and have
young kids and and I think we all that's
part of who we are and we think about
that and but more importantly it's about
the scale of the story so for instance
isn't necessary and is it narrative ly
significant and is it an is it warranted
if those if you can answer those
questions and you feel you need
something that's that you know could be
shocking or violent then what's the most
artful way to handle that so that you
don't alienate the audience and I think
that with this film yes of course
the anos is chopped at the top is is was
was a tricky one we tried to handle it
in the way that we thought was best but
part of the story is is you know Thor
dealing with something that he really
shouldn't maybe have done I mean he
loses it a bit there and I think it's
also shocking and it's also final at
least for Santos in that in that in that
timeline so it's like you really it
seemed to make sense but yeah we're
always mindful of that sort of thing I
think that also you know with some of
the violence in the fighting and in the
battle sequences there's a I want to say
there's a difference in terms of there's
a there's an unreality to these movies
there they are they are in of a science
fiction fantasy context so there's a
level of that that is slightly
abstracted from what you know what is
real and so you still want them to have
sort of a visceral impact you want the
characters to feel it
but at the same time people are doing
things that you know people sometimes
cannot do that said never want to be
ghoulish or you know we're not trying to
celebrate it and we're also trying to
make sure that there's consequences to
it I think that's one of the things I
like a lot about end game is that you
can watch these superhero movies the
ones that have real consequence you know
we lose people in this movie people that
we care about we've followed for years
as a story arc but the feeling of loss
it's real they're gone they're not
coming back this isn't a
they're not gonna come back by some
magic you know spell in another future
film so it's very much like you have to
say goodbye and that shows the
consequence of those actions and I think
that's actually something that drama
does for all of us is we get to
experience consequence and emotion that
we would experience in real life but
experience in drama it's a it's a way to
sort of if you see what that feels like
you know in a safe place